this is your first red carpet how do you
feel
excited I've been nervous it's a lot of
emotions right now but I'm happy
yeah that's amazing you are coming into
the MCU real strong what was it like
training to be such a Powerhouse
character
we have we spend one year training
physical mental and we we are free
diving we hold our breath under the
water we made an amazing job there so it
was really hard actually yeah really
really hard well we actually hear that
you hold your breath your first time
that you went down it was eight minutes
well it was six and a half
you deserve it yes no but they're not
actually did an amazing job too was
actually five minutes I think or
something like that the dedication that
you have all to that and speaking of the
dedication you know we've seen in the
trailer blue skin now we want to know
there's some there's some cast squares
out here they painted their skin blue
did you have to do that or was it CGI
what was that process like well I spent
six hours for that process for for being
blue
six hours and actually we are starting
eight hours and and well the the the the
time the final time was six hours but
maybe you can see in the movie another
memory we know their skin I don't know
so I love the teaser the mystery there
yeah that's good let's see what's
happened yes we're into it now tell us
what it was like to play a woman from a
really powerful cultural background we
know that nomura is all about protecting
her people give us a little insight into
that experience oh it's a love because I
I think
thanks for the Legacy The Chadwick
Legacy the notch Alex and me now we have
the opportunity to represent our
cultural over a letting kill to rest so
as a Mexican woman it's an amazing
experience it can can play nomura in in
this universe you know because the the
we in Mexico exists a lot of faces yeah
so I am very proud that people like like
me like with my face with my skin with
my other cool tour can be in this huge
platform so I'm very excited about it
yes the fans are also equally excited
they love you so much they're excited
for the splash I'm sorry I had to the
splash we're gonna make I'm sorry bad
jokes here but thank you so much for
spending your time out here everybody
wants to go and talk to you so we're
going to send you on your way have a
great night congratulations thank you
Mabel cadeta let's take advantage of the
Marvel fans thank you